[Music]
went to the left hand and blew a tire on
his way up
mellow now danny green on him between
the legs gets him up in the air and a
foul
and count it redemption for carmelo
[Music]
anthony
gentlemen now carmilla's gonna turn at
the base
no jumps into the key and draws the foul
and hits just show it boom you know
everybody wants to
block or defend the big all-star future
hall of famer
pj just gets caught with the hand in the
cookie chart
five consecutive games he's got 30 or
better to tie
his
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
baseline jumper is good how many times
have you seen this movie mike
as a nick announcer come out at me on
the block post it up
little patented turnaround fade away
jump shot
thing of beauty he is averaging 16 and a
half points per game
damien with it up top they switch it
with o'neill now on hill
carmelo faces up and holds out of it
beats him on the crossover and it powers
to
[Music]
[Music]
as this game continues to progress mccaw
and inoby if they continue to see major
minutes they got to give him something
went to the left hand and blew a tire on
his way up
mello now danny green on him between the
legs gets him up in the air and a foul
and count it
redemption for carmelo anthony oh my god
melo can't go back in his bag he can't
well i'm telling you as an nba veteran
[Music]
rose trying to challenge whiteside who
canceled that shot
now the blazers pick and pop carmelo
from cj
got it that combination has been working
all night long
and then cj after a stellar night comes
off the basketball
and gives mellow the pick and pop
that's the dimension mellow has added
from day one
lillard one on one with allen drives
kicks it out anthony anthony for three
bang
carmelo anthony makes it a six-point
game
20 seconds remaining big three-pointers
from anthony once again
if i put the ball in your hands as a
license to make the play not the score
damon lillard unselfish superstar
seven seconds carmelo
raptors will have 3.3 seconds to
[Music]
does a nice job being patient and
carmelo anthony just steps right up
into the open spot and anovi helps off
and
his help creates the lane
for mello to go to work what up it's
your boy adam lefkow did you like that
content i know you like that content hit
subscribe
for more of it from bleacher report